[Musique]
jacqueline
ça fait cinq ans que je vis avec elle
jacqueline c'est ma soeur
je n'ai pas envie de faire un laïus sur
l'inceste je veux simplement dire que je
vis différemment que les autres mais
avec les mêmes envies les mêmes désirs
et j'ai envie de les réaliser
pas parce qu'on a le même sang qui coule
dans nos veines qu'on n'aurait pas le
droit de s'aimer de et de faire tout ce
que les autres couples ce nom
mais qui vous l'interdît personne
personne et tout un foin
personne ouvertement ou des
dix si l'on en sait des choses puisque
10 sport mais consent simplement
[Musique]
alors pourquoi ces besoins de dire aux
autres ce que ça va pas transformer
votre vie
oui sûrement
parce que c'est pas facile nous raconter
sa vie aux lions de tonton toni
en a marre de vivre cachés on veut dire
une bonne fois pour tout pour essayer de
vivre simplement heureux
simplement
quand j'étais môme
toit s 14 ans je m'endormais soir et
puis je vais non mes fantasmes se
ferment lille vers bourg une femme qui
arrivait tout en blanc est le multi
superbe donc dans la réalité géo luxe à
ce rapprochement au maximum
et quand j'allais avec des filles et je
sentais que c'était pas vraiment ça ne
collait pas vraiment bien est incapable
de faire quoi que ce soit
ok et jacqueline
c'est parti je me suis donner elle s'est
donnée
c'était la femme vous attendiez
bonjour
ce thème
j'attendais j'ai attendu longtemps
c'est la première fois que vous vivez
qui sommes
[Applaudissements]
en parlant de jacqueline on doit dire
votre soeur votre femme votre ami en
bois séché
c'est
fait c'est fait pas vraiment chérie fais
pas un problème c'est pas la seule
c'est pas une amie non plus et plus
jacqueline
et ce qu'andré est encore votre frère
est ce que vous le considérez comme
votre frère non j'ai jamais sentie andré
en tant que frais je crois que l'amour
l'attrait physique que j'ai pour lui
dépasse ça je crois mais vous y pensez
de temps en temps non jamais non je me
sens en sécurité je me sens protégée
mais c'est ce que j'attends d'un homme
de toute façon
est ce qu on me sert à parler avec un
frère
je sais pas je sais pas on n'a pas
grandi au sommet on est une famille de
10 enfants et on n'a pas connu les
parents parce que tout petit on a été
séparée pour des raisons qu'on n'a
jamais su on a été placé deux par deux
dans des orphelinats ou des familles
nourricière et j'ai passé comme ça que
j'ai palais kfw qu'andré
mois jacqueline ces mesures parce qu'on
a les mêmes parents
en fait j'ai rencontré il ya sept ans
était une étrangère pour me laver
avec mon sens le rapport affectif
jacqueline c'est ma seule langue qu'est
ce que ça veut dire c'est ainsi qu'on
s'est rencontré il ya sept ans après
on s'était donné rendez vous à
l'occasion d'un conseil
et
audrey a pris contact avec moi et
dominici soit on devrait tous déjà rêver
et moi quand je suis arrivé où je
cherchais dans la salle et dès que j'ai
su que c'était andré j'avais rendez vous
avec toi quand vous êtes tombés dans les
bras dans d'autres comme ça soit vous
passez vite
s'est pas fait parce qu'on dit encore ce
après deux ans essayez de je me disais
c'est pas possible c'est mon frère est
faux c'est nous pas y penser
quand on perd aussi et férocité d'autres
attendent un déclic quand il ya un
déclic s'est produit en soirée là c'est
ce qu'on pouvait pour en parler
donc vous ne vous êtes pas vus comme des
étrangers et ça vous a bloqué en fait
oui ben et they 9 avenue q
pas vraiment si tu veux face aux a
bloqué parce que
moi j'avais peur de sa réaction elle
avait plein des miennes enfin pas
forcément peur mais à la connaissent pas
ils restent sur une chacun ce qu'on
avait on n'en parlait pas de ça
[Musique]
je me voyais pas dire à jacques est vrai
qu envie de faire l'amour et seulement
tabasseurs question penser tout me dire
ça casse tout c'était impossible de
faire comme ça parce que moi je me
disais bon mois ci si année
si aller contre dieu et tout ça moi
j'avais pas envie de casser la mythique
était quand même là trois mêmes aussi
oui mais c'est donc vous pensiez que
l'autre vous considérez comme ou comme
le frère ou une soeur anna non non non
non c'est pas qu'on pensait que nous
conte c'est parce qu'on savait pas ce
que votre pensée exactement du problème
de l'inceste en fait vous n'avez pas
conscience vous de commettre non si si
tu veux c'est obligé qu'on veuille en
avait conscience mais ça m'était égal
le lendemain matin je vais pas me
réveiller
[Musique]
c'est chiant parce que des fois une fois
que c'est consommer aussi des points des
réactions me semble un peu différent de
soi l'espère puis en fait en fait
mon dieu bleu plein de tendresse
moi j'ai senti tout de suite que je vais
trouver un compagnon qui pouvait
accepter tout l'amour que je pouvais
donner
mais depuis baron sais pas qui tu es
c'était la main jour là
c'est pas pour toi comment c'était
[Musique]
quitterie mai
mais mettra un peu plus par la voilà
mais c'est un peu top
voilà je bouge plus et on devrait vous
apporter ce que vous cherchiez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui oui la première personne à qui j'ai
pu me confier entièrement qui m'a écouté
et qui m'a compris
qui m'a aimée en fait
ne riez pas une connaissance est votre
lien de parenté
ce que vous pensez vous seriez en train
de vivre cette même passion
comment vous l'expliquez cette passion
à mon avis on est comme ça on se connaît
a vécu un peu la misère affective mais
ça rien à voir
parce qu on est frères et soeurs et une
personne quand j'ai vécu comme ça là
même un petit avec une passion aussi
forte le bateau
est en fait c'est plus la solitude est
et ce qu'on a vécu qui a fait un chrono
france m6 force tu parce que jacqueline
par exemple parce que vous voyez où
vivre une relation amoureuse avec michel
votre frère mais qui vous avez grandi
pas du tout non justement pas du tout ce
que d'abord aux amish année-là il a pas
il a pas de sexe c j'ai beaucoup de
tendresse pour lui j'aime les souvenirs
où il ya tout le temps présent de tout
le temps présent justement une tout
petit
et puis ça
c'est pas possible parce que je pense
que dans dans une famille
les gens soient sexuelles
c'est donc en fait une condamnation
d'inceste que vous faites là ah oui pour
moi
j'aurais pas pu vivre ça ni avec michel
d'ailleurs ni avec le fils de la
nourrice par exemple
alors que
alors qu'elle est avec andré finalement
je me retrouve dans une situation assez
seul alors pour moi je trouve que les
comptes ou une parce que je n'ai pas
grandi ensemble
et votre entourage vos amis sont au
courant de votre situation
qui sont un faux compte de notre
situation il ya des gens qui sont pas du
tout au courant des gens qu'on voit
qu'on aime bien et que l'on sente si on
leur disait la réalité
sacré ce cas serait quelque chose qu'on
n'a pas envie forcément le classement on
trouve ça un peu gros
à part à cinq ans ont fait très
attention il s'agit
dans le monde de travail
jusqu'à mars etc ouais au boulot on dit
pas est
vite
sa commande et puis ça dépend aussi des
gens quand ménage tous les jours un mail
à vous prenez le risque que tout le
monde la prenne pourquoi courir ce
risque
parce qu'on en a marre de faire
attention à ce qu'on dit je le ferai que
rencontre des gens sur mon travail
n'importe où on veut dire une bonne fois
et
je sais tout pu en parler je n'ai et vos
frères et soeurs ce qui le ca non parce
que je les connais pas tous et puis ça
que j'ai vu j'ai vu aussi peu
l'après midi à dimanche
et puis le pin j'ai fait moi aussi
on sait jamais revu ça n'a pas été
facile de retrouver ces quelques frères
et soeurs
mais la famille on avait envie de les
voir pour me parler
leur dire pourquoi vous recherchez une
passion familiale
peut-être j'avais envie de leur dire que
andré moment s'étaient retrouvées non
pas comme frères et soeurs mais comme
couple avec les mêmes désirs et c'est
important des réactions qu'il n'aura pas
bien sûr et puis bon un soir un soir je
suis resté pour être un peu
plus loin dans notre
dans notre votre approche en plein jour
là bas on sait pas tout est donc
nommé sur la je viens avec andrey depuis
maintenant ça fait cinquante
dacquois
[Applaudissements]
nous à nous a posé des problèmes avant
impôts mais j'ai tout misé en français
dans un sens je pense que ça se comprend
sucre puisque ça pouvait vous avez connu
c'était les ai connus comme ton
rencontre mon petit garçon
quand on la prend un point c'est un choc
un peu mais si on va prêcher un peu je
pense que vous ce que vous c'est quelque
chose que vous pensez que vous à vos
frais
jamais les bourthois
non mais parce que pour moi
c'était mon frère que
de questions mais c'est tout ce que ça
comporte donc frère père et oncle 15
un diction donc dans cet ordre d'idées
la non ça n'est pas venu à l'idée sûrs
de leur
système et un enfant dans mon idée de
monde y pense au début on était ensemble
ce concept de guillaume toute façon dans
un palais enfants et puis le temps passe
ont enseigné bat paul pourquoi
aujourd'hui on vit ovi com je vais
emmener un coup d'abord et sept enfants
il aura un père et une mère ce qu'il
faut c'est effectivement le protéger par
rapport à l'extérieur parce que ce n'est
pas qu'on montre du doigt
parce que ses parents son frère et soeur
parce qu'elle est assez pensé c'est
l'enfant aura
[Musique]
à la base il y aura des parents comme
tous les autres mais il arrivera
toujours à savoir s'il faut pas que je
ne sois n'a pas envie de le cacher soit
pas risquer pour le problème je veux
c'est traumatisant pour la grotte de
découvrir qui
imagina par rapport à ce que ses copains
d'école tous ces enfants il t'appartient
ton qui va pas l'école une fois qui va à
l'école et un maintien plus de ses
copains et parlent entre eux c'est toute
la vie sexuelle des enfants une simple
du prince entre eux ont eu tellement de
patois petit monde est concerné trois
quarts
quand je joue bien aux fans donc entre
eux ils vont en discuter et six trophées
sous ta fille de dix sept petites
copines de mon père c'est le frère ma
soeur anna bergin oui mais la petite
copine veut dire sa mère et ça va faire
et ce pendant toute la soirée au repos
et après ça va tout les corps et sans
elle ça va retomber ce gamin
tu peux pas empêcher ça
et c'est à ce moment là qu'on se demande
comment lui valent vivre même si
c'est sûr qu'il va revenir bientôt plus
mal que dans un couple déchiré lusambo
de laisser nos vies n'a mais c'est cette
situation-là qui livre un peu forcément
bien
je crois que ce qu'on veut nous c'est
beau le protéger et le dire mais on est
quand même dans une situation
exceptionnelle et il donnait pas par
notre amour notre présence là la force
de répondre aux attaques de l'extérieur
c'est sévère un enfant et un jour y
trouve du fils de [ __ ] comme des
questions et jugera
[Applaudissements]
j'y vais
avec mon frère
[Musique]
pour bien des choses point de vue une
bombe à 10,6 à sion servette évident
point de vue de l'enfant point de vue
des risques qu'ils encourent d'être
rocher de la société d'être plus normal
dans mon choix pris cette décision
[Musique]
mais en faire pour penser aussi à ça
qu'on couche ccd fois pas toujours la
vie effectivement qu'un gosse divorce et
le divorce et ça souffre mais dans cette
situation
je pense qu'il soufflera encore plus
spécialement tu peux pas savoir si tu
veux jouer 25 ans
19 h 15 que tous aillent amène dans la
lente
chacun fait ce qu'il veut enfin moi je
trouve que
les noms
maintenant je te dis ce que je pense
puisque je pense d'étrangers vous vous
êtes connus comme frères et soeurs vous
êtes devenu marié femmes en quelque
sorte et maintenant vous avez décidé
d'être père et mère qu'est ce que ça
change pour vous
ça change je crois qu'on met on tire un
trait définitivement sûr sûr sûr le fait
qu on est frères et ça c'est pas plus qu
on entérine une façon définitive
parce que d'abord parce que on est en
train de créer notre propre famille et
c'est dans celle là en fait dans
laquelle on se reconnaît le plus parce
que bon nous a présenté comme étant
frères et soeurs on se retrouve comme
deux étrangers face à face avec quelques
années ça peut vraiment pas dire grand
chose jusque là en tant que père et mère
on se reconnaît pas ou n'existe vraiment
c'est important pour vous de créer une
famille
quand on fait moins
quand on sait moins c'est que c'est plus
qu'important c'est nécessaire et joe
taux importants
mais les conséquences et les risques
pour l'enfant les connaissez vous allez
jusqu'au bout
on a déjà eu une expérience
jacqueline a déjà était enceinte de moi
une fois et on l'a fait passer on a
inventé parce qu'on
attendrait son nom parce qu'on se posait
à perdre un peu trop de questions par
rapport à
on a eu peur je crois on avait peur de
peur de l'inconnu peur la réaction des
gens qui étaient défavorables
c'est les gens qui nous ont fait avoir
la trouille cheveux parce que les gens
nous ont dit ouais vous êtes frères et
soeurs
conserver une qualité bien édité d'aimer
les gens très proches de nous des amis
des copains des gens qu'on aimait bien
qu'ils comprendront quand même toi c'est
des gens quand ils me disent quelque
chose on roule
on écoute on ressent et nous donc c'est
ces gens là qui nous ont fait peur est
jamais qu il y
ait maintenant n'avaient plus peur
même plus maintenant c'était assez dur
parce que cet enfant le voulait déjà à
ce moment là et puis
et puis bon on n'a pas peur n'a pas osé
aller jusqu'au bout on a eu peur la
difficulté de rencontrer des gens à qui
on avec qui on pouvait s'ouvrir
et puis voir la suite de sarlat et
longuement réfléchi au problème on a
envisagé différentes solutions
différentes possibilités
adopter un enfant
entre autres
bon là ça n'a pas été possible parce que
la mesure où on est frères et soeurs et
on vit ensemble mettant hors de question
qu'on nous donne un enfant
élevé donc ça s'était exclu on a
envisagé
la possibilité d'une insémination
artificielle bon ça c'est quelque chose
qu'on n'a pas gardé parce que vous savez
quelque chose un peu personnel si tout
va bien c'est ensemble toutes façons
finalement aujourd'hui le faire ensemble
c'est une
question que ce soit quelqu'un d'autre
ou donc
on
s'aime on serre les rangs ensemble je
veux dire en plus je veux dire les
années de bonheur pour nous à elles ont
été elles sont courtes jeudi a
finalement j'ai presque trente ans ça
fait cinq ans qu'on est ensemble ça fait
cinq ans qu'on est comme moi je suis
vraiment heureuse ja pas pourquoi
j'aurais pas un enfant d'andré dans la
mesure où c'est
ce que je désire le plus
de lui et pas quelqu'un de doux parce
que c'est lui qui m'apporte ça et je
peux pas lui apporter mieux qu'un enfant
je veux dire c'est lui qui m'a rendue
heureuse et moi
je veux je peux que lui dire d'enfants
comme celle ci lui même le plus beau
cadeau que je puisse cus
un souci n'avait pas écouté les autres
employés
et c'est important les autres
bâtiments
maintenant ça y est je veux dire bon
ballon on peut mentionner mais j'ai
maintenant ce dont j'étais en et les
routes et les mêmes presque là déjà et
ça c'est de l'histoire ancienne je veux
dire maintenant c'est genre on a franchi
le pas on a décidé que de toute façon
c'est normal quand on est un enfant dont
on a envie de cet enfant et tout le
reste c'est c'est plus nos
préoccupations en fait maintenant
pendant un moment on a voulu garder ce
secret pour nous et puis jouer sans le
milieu médical c'était prendre un peu
trop de risques
[Musique]
quatre fois plus de chance
le couple de voir l'enfant
on
nous a dit que je suis un fou était bien
est ce qu'on soit
le problème pour lui et sa descendance
il est médecin comment ils réagissent à
votre histoire
[Musique]
c'est à dire que bon j'ai commencé à
faire suivre ma grossesse dans un
hôpital
est bon car j'ai eu des bons rapports
avec les colocs qui m'a reçu d'ailleurs
le gel de ses lives en sts est marqué en
gros consanguinité ce qui fait que bon
le rapport a été faussé dès le départ la
main ça passait dans les mains des
secrétaires dans les mains des des
infirmières
jeu léché gynécologues etc combattant de
mettre une pancarte et puis c'est la
même chose quoi c'est difficile à dire
sa gynécologue à dire voilà on est
frères et soeurs c'est à dire que dans
cet hôpital là oui c'est difficile à
dire et dans cet hôpital là c'est le
conseil de ma gynéco là qui me suivait
depuis un petit moment elle nous avait
conseillés pour - orthez et moins choqué
donc la sensibilité du médecin vous avez
dit de dire qu'on était cousin germain
ce que j'ai fait alors bon si j'avais
été freinée tes frères et soeurs alors
là je pense qu'il serait arrivé mais
enfin bon depuis n'ont pas changé depuis
notamment beaucoup
c'est
pas besoin de moins en moins de
contraction
[Musique]
parce qu'on a passé le cap des vies mois
et a donc eu des contractions je vais
les gars décontraction toujours débattue
mais non en plus comme chaque fois on
avait des conventions on a des angoisses
d'acteur c'est la première fois que vous
êtes confrontés ce genre de situation
oui
oui c'est la première fois que je vois
j'ai déjà vu pas mal de choses mais ça
je n'ai pas encore vu ni entendu
c'est à dire est ce que ça vous pose des
problèmes particuliers en tant que
médecin aucun
aucun problème particulier dans la
mesure où eux
je ne suis pas là pour juger qui que ce
soit je ne rate aucun ordre moral
je ne suis pas là pour ça c'est pas bon
produit un problème je sais le rêve
j'essaie de les aider mais c'est pas
j'ai pas
morales a porté sur quoi que ce soit
c'est pas mon travail ça c'est pas moi
je vais faire vous n'avez pas été choqué
lorsque jacqueline nous a expliqué sa
situation si on lit la bible par exemple
de l'ancien testament je crois que tout
était possible
le complexe d'oedipe ça vient de quelque
chose connaissent les problèmes
finalement allé qu'est-ce que je n'ai
dit que
les anomalies métaboliques possible et
c'est rare et ils savent que c'est
l'esclandre x le fait de la
consanguinité
mais je crois qu'ils ne savaient qu'ils
ont atterri ce
que nous a aussi déterminé à poursuivre
c'est que nous aviez aussi que si bon
enfant goûter tout à fait aux normes à
la naissance et franchissait le cap mais
pas de problème non plus pour lui
mais pour vous l'interdît de l'inceste
repose sur les dangers engendrés par la
course en 2 limité assure l'emportent
c'est sûrement effectivement des vaches
crois pas je ne crois pas je pense que
c'est plutôt des principes édictés par
des règles morales de la morale dans
laquelle on vit dans la morale judéo
chrétienne
parce qu'il tendra à dire qu'il n'ya pas
plus de risques avoir un enfant en
famille
donc ça je rentrais pas loin non ça
c'est pas vrai du tout il ya un risque
c'est vrai
ça très bien
on remonte voyez le coeur qui bat
parfaitement bien l'iq routes l'aorte
l'abdomen de l'enfant avec la v6 qui est
le gros trou noir l'intestin à côté
du rhin
chaque côté
rassurant de savoir que j'attends que
vous connaissez fait que celles non
la sélection
alors qu'il
est quand même là visibles avec une
commission des canisses de quoi donc une
carte étudiant les plaintes à
celles qui pouvaient y en aura c'est le
tri et les petits blancs que vous voyez
les petits flocons
moi je veux le reconnaître comme bear
signer fois jacqueline y arriver quelque
chose d'imprévu nos prévisible qu'elle
disparaît subitement jeu absolument
avoir tous les droits sur le mot
absolument tous
ça c'est ma grosse préoccupation
avoir avoir les droits et qu'ils soient
pas seul parce que bon qu'est ce qui va
se passer six mois à sa mère disparaît
bon de se retrouver la séance publique
ça c'est quelque chose qu'on veut
absolument aux questions de l'assistance
publique oui mais vous avoir été volé
leur savoir très bien comment ça marche
quoi donc on veut pas reproduire ça du
tout et de toute façon c'est moi le père
c'est moi
qu'il est conçu avec jacqueline souhaite
qu'il ait fait y'a pas de raisons qu'on
connaît donc la raison commande et
je me demande aussi dans quelle limite
on pourrait pas nous retirer cet enfant
dans la mesure où ce qu'on vit et et
moral aux yeux de la société
[Musique]
m libre man est ce que l'enfant d'andré
de jacqueline pourrait leur être enlevés
pour immoralité
condition que les parents se tiennent
bien le seul fait qu'ils soient des
parents incestueux ne peut pas être
considéré à mon sens comme une preuve
d'une moralité par contre si ces parents
là comme d'autres d'ailleurs faisait
preuve d'une moralité dans leur vie et
surtout si l'intérêt de l'enfant
pouvait en dépendre de cette immoralité
la dass pour est incontestablement
intervenir chez l'enfant et pour un
motif différent je inceste
andré est venue s'informer sur les lois
concernant l'inceste pourquoi votre
entrevue ne peut être filmé n'a pas pu
être filmée parce qu' il est impossible
en vertu de nos règles professionnelles
qu'une consultation donner un client
quel qu'il soit soit rendue publique
dans la législation française rien
n'interdit l'inceste
rien n'interdit d'inceste sur le plan
pénal qu'on ne peut pas être traduits
pour inceste devant la cour d'assises ou
devant un tribunal correctionnel
par contre il ya certaines règles
d'interdiction au plan du droit civil
exemple on ne peut pas se marier et ceci
est si vrai il ya certes un doctrinaire
du droit qui on parlait de trois zones
d'interdiction allant
véritablement de la pire
jusqu'à
celle qu'on peut admettre
et on a parlé dans un premier cas de
zone d'horreur
la zone d'horreur ont dit certains
c'est l'inceste absolue le père et la
fille le frère et la soeur oui cette
zone dite d'horreur est valable aussi
dans ce cas c'est à dire deux personnes
qui se connaissent à l'âge adulte parce
que ses frères et les soeurs les
doctrinaires met dans la zone d'horreur
c'est à dire dans le cas d'inceste
abstenus le frère et la soeur sans
distinguer six se sont connus à l'âge
adulte ou mais vous m liman est ce que
vous ne pensez pas qu'il ya carence dans
la loi dans ce cas précis
je ne peux pas vous le dire en tout cas
si certains parlementaires reconnaissait
le mérite de cette situation était
sensible à cette situation et au
comportement particulièrement sein de ce
couple en dehors des problèmes de
génétique des problèmes médicaux
peut-être des problèmes religieux qui ne
doivent pas être mes propos aujourd'hui
peut-être que le législateur pourrait
être sensible à une proposition de loi
qui complèterait l'article du code civil
permettant au président de la république
d'accorder une dérogation l'enfant
d'andré de jacqueline va bientôt naître
tant qu andré qui se trouve dans le cas
d'inceste absolue ne peut pas
reconnaître son enfant soit andré soit
jacqueline c'est à dire soit le père
soit la mer n'est pas les deux car il
est interdit en vertu du code civil que
la filiation soit établie au nom des
deux parents ainsi si un problème à la
naissance
vous vous sentez assez fort pour
l'assumer oui
de temps maintenant peut plus revenir en
arrière ou avec de l'avant donc
donc oui la précision on puisera
énergie
en face on était obligé de mon on a
décidé d'avoir un enfant
quoi qu'il advienne on prendra les
décisions qu'on a envie de prendre
jusqu'au bout de papier
que ces dissidents soit
juste ou fausse rapport un système donné
c'est pas le problème le problème c'est
une année une décision par parra nous
parce qu'on a envie de faire un c'est
tout si
on fasse ancien naissance il arrivait à
une catastrophe qui meurt on est prêt à
recommencer parce que c'est un chouette
on a fait ça allait si on vire elle est
privée maintenant on va jusqu'au bout
s'il y a un problème vous recommencez
vous refaites un autre en face
de tous la layette romanum on à l'envi
on a tourné le désire on a tout pour
refaire
ça n'aurait aucune incidence sur votre
couple
s'il y avait un ennui
ça on peut pas dire je
sais les réactions des fois t'es
contrepoids
c'est comme un couple
normal d'un couple qui arrive un pépin
et ma vie se retrouve en face à prendre
une décision nous ça sera la même chose
on se retrouve dans une situation de
marginalité et etc on n'a pas voulu et
on ne veut pas ça veut dire à nos
préoccupations sont nos désirs nos
espoirs nous désespoir bombasse et c'est
la vie c'est la vie de tout le monde
c'est la vie de chacun et pourquoi les
uns qui ne seraient plus les autres et
pourquoi nous on serait on serait plus
plus en marre je veux dire nous cesser
une situation que qu'on rejette
complètement je t'en veux pas on n'est
pas en marge de quoi que ce soit j'ai
envie tous les jours dans une société
qui est
et c'est tout l enfant aucune louis
l'enfant il sera de toutes façons
marginalisés non au départ
pourquoi ce pas google au contraire il a
un père une mère des gens qui l'aiment
qui l'entourent
non pourquoi ils seraient marginalisés
au contraire il ya il ya des enfants qui
sont beaucoup beaucoup moins privilégiés
qu'ils n'ont finalement
[Musique]
s'il arrive
normal soit dix ans sans problème
et l'arrivée que même chose que tous les
autres enfants
ah ah
qu'est ce que vous lui direz à cet
enfant quand elle sera plus grande
moi je vais essayer de lui dire
toutes les choses qu'on m'a caché la vie
sur l'amour la tendresse
réfection les choses qu'on n'apprend pas
je crois que si j'arrive à ça ça dépend
pas forcément non plus de moi
parce qu'à un moment ou un autre il faut
pas qu'elle sorte de la seule famille
mais quand elle vous posera des
questions parce que ses parents sont
différents des autres qu'est ce que vous
lui explique ray parce que vous lui
direz
sur le fait qu'on soit frères et soeurs
bon je l'ignoré je lui dirai pas le
rapport à jour je dirais thiam a
aujourd'hui je vais lui dire qu on est
frères et soeurs tout ça ça fait partie
de la vie quotidienne c'est comme mon
bébé appelle sa mère maman est là nous
appellerons
bon à part ça
soit
normalement
votre votre soeur aînée françoise
vous ai dit que c'était sévère un enfant
et qu'un jour elle vous jugerez très
sévèrement qu'est ce que vous en pensez
moi je pense que c'est vrai je pense que
le moi je pense que j'ai fait pareil que
mes parents
même si je n'ai pas connu à une époque
de ma vie j'étais très sévère j'étais
même jusqu'à vouloir les retrouver pour
les tuer c'est un peu fort ce que j'ai
passé assez vite après élection mais
c'est vrai que quand tu es monde qui
fait de cadeau à personne
et en même temps ils ont raison
penser qu'elle vous en voudra
je pense pas
je crois pas
je fais sur lui donner les moyens
vendeuse de vivre heures
heureuses qu'on ne pas vivre
comme quand je me suis retrouvé tout
seul non on angoisse de savoir où
j'allais qui j'étais
mais justement cette situation
particulière risque de lui créer à son
tour ces mêmes difficultés c'est même
peur vis-à-vis de l'extérieur qui vous
lie peut-être aussi fort à jacqueline
oui certainement
c'est pour ça qu'on a décidé de se
battre donc notre coupe soit reconnue
et qu'elle ne vivent pas comme une tare
ou une marginalité
[Musique]
donc on a assez souffert de votre
enfance pour l'aider à affronter
extérieur l'inconnu
dont 100 à vapeur
puisse affronter la vie quoi
[Musique]